and guess who's taking the mound
right-hander matt manning we've talked
about him for a while now and he's got
to be excited to pitch in front of his
home crowd here
for the first time at comerica park in
the big leagues
pounded to deep right center field that
goes mazzara
shy of the wall he hauls it in and
manning gets the best of carlson in
their first clash
strikes him out for out number two the
one-two he jammed him it's a looper into
center willie castro is there and
14 pitches needed from matt manning in
his comerica park debut
john gant has seen his era jump from 160
to 3-5-0
in his last three starts swinging a mess
through the kitchen sink at him and that
about the good thing is too right there
is
he knows that's a strike back-to-back
case for john gantz
well you can't argue with that but like
you said good pitches
down at the bottom of the zone i don't
know how you can argue that one
the 2-2 pitch and there's a high fly
ball center field moving to his right
over toward left center carlson
and he makes the catch candelario is out
number three and we go to the second
nothing nothing in detroit
big challenge for matt manning here in
the second starting with nolan arnotto
in the air deep left at the wall
gone nolan aronado
puts the cardinals on top with his 14th
home run
one-nothing st louis oronato with a solo
home run
here in the second you want to know
something too he just missed that ball
just missed it because if he had to hit
that ball where that swing
the connection watch where he's at he's
got good extension right here
just missed hitting it flush and that
ball would have went a
long way a long way here's large new bar
played left field last night he's in
right field today
and the 2-0 is hit into the gap in right
center there you go and that ball is
down large newt barr
is first ever big league hit it's going
to be a triple
into third large newt barr first major
league hit in detroit it's a triple
he can run too gotta love it well you
knew it was coming just a matter of time
such a good swing short tommy edmond a
chance to add to the cardinals one
nothing lead ground ball
base head into center large newt barr
will score
edmond makes it a two nothing cardinal
lead
here in the top of the third jake rogers
leads off for the tigers 9-1-2 hitters
for the 3-2
blowing away good at bat jake rogers
draws the walk
the 3-1 back-to-back walks to start the
third
for the second straight inning now
they've got their big gun up
jonathan scope scope drives one to right
center field
that's going to find the alley off the
wall
one run is home but dew is right on
rogers tail
that is a two-run double for jonathan
scope
and we are tied jonathan's skull keeping
that red-hot bat
going he gets a pitch very handable
pitch that fastball down the middle but
for him to drive in the runners and you
saw how badou was off to the races he
was trying to catch jake rogers right
there
bounce right back but capitalizing on
those two walks
both those guys come around to score
making the pitcher pay look at the
bottom of the fourth inning dez cameron
leads off for the tigers
cameron that's a blast to deep left
field and that is
way gone tigers have the lead
on daz cameron's solo shot to lead off
the four
a no doubter for daz cameron there
and he's starting to show a little bit
of that pop that some of the people have
been talking about
kind of surprised by it but boy did he
jump all over this pitch
off-speed pitch it looked like it was
his change up and daz waited back
beautiful i'm sure
craig monroe is gonna break that one
down but no doubter
he hit it and he hit it a long way
jonathan scope leads off for the tigers
fifth inning two three four hitters
the 2-2 to scope a drive to left
he did it again jonathan scope is
unbelievable oh my he tried to slip that
fastball
buy him down and in and look at this
swing
he comes and just drops the barrel
straight down
it was short and compact but the whole
key to the
these great hits that we're seeing out
of scope is how quickly
he gets the bat to the ball and barrels
it up
that was just phenomenal right there now
kale badou is the batter
he's over two a walk and a run scored
good job right field castro scores
a little hesitation by paredes and
he's caught at the plate this is classic
i love what i just saw there yada yada
molina gave him the lane right
he has to catch the ball before it was a
great slide
look at what freddy's just can't get
back
to home plate another move to first and
a close play
safe over at first the call by nick
lentz that was a quick throw
by gallegos and carpenter caught the
ball right on the
back shoulder and he's going to be out
he is he's picked off
and that ends the bottom of the sixth
inning tigers get a run on the badoo
single the tigers with a 5-2 lead in the
bottom of the eighth
and giovanni gallegos remains in this
ball game
oronato throw up the line and the tag
applied by carpenter well done
defensively
nice play both sides of that runners at
the corners with only one away
here's esau paradise fly ball
right field lars newt barr camps under
it the tag is made
by cameron he will score and the tigers
make it a four
run lead aj hinch
turns the ninth inning over to michael
fulmer
a line drive that's a short hop nope
they're going to say he caught it
in the air willie castro retires tyler
o'neal to start the ninth
the o2 half cut did he go yes he did
appeal down to first
beautiful slider down and away molina
went too far two outs in the ninth
good breaking ball sharpness to it
molina didn't like to call
another payoff hate got him looking
[Applause]
what a way to start the home stand now
what a way to start the career of matt
manning
the first of many for the young tigers
right-hander
he wins in his home debut in front of
13 000 plus and in front of his family
here in detroit